I'm Ryan Vaughn producer on the sims 4
and I want to give you a deeper look at
create a sin we've completely reinvented
our technology so that created sim is
tactile more intuitive and much more
powerful I'm going to create Bela and
Mortimer goth two of my favorite Sims of
all time we've seen them at different
ages throughout Sims history but let's
see what they look like in The Sims 4
from this panel I'll quickly select a
face for Bella and then give her body
shape Bella's active she's fit but she's
always been a woman with curves I just
push and pull on a region and give her
shape in the sims 3 I could make a lot
of different looking sims but I had to
work through multiple men use to create
the same I wanted to in the sims 4
direct manipulation makes creating sims
faster and easier branda sim is more
powerful letting me craft my sims from
head to toe
they're simply more to play with oh all
right let's get back to Bella with the
variety of facial features I have to
play with I can finally create Sims that
look like they truly come from around
the world Bella's looking good and I can
create her husband Mortimer in just a
few clicks
but I want to go deeper in detail mode
regions are highlighted letting me know
exactly what I can tweet I can really
finesse the appearance of my sims with
this level of control I begin to bring
out their personalities Mortimer's a bit
older he needs some wrinkles and Bella a
great big smile now let's play with
their style I can choose Bella's hair
and plan their outfits there's
accessories
make up to add
and even tattoos sorry Mort you're not
an Incan of guy we've added something
called styled looks where I can find a
great look fast ladies and gentlemen
meet Mortimer and Bella goth sims 4
style for me the magic of creation is in
making Sims of my friends and people I
know from the real world ok this is a
picture of me and this is the same i've
been working on what do you think
creating a sim with this level of detail
is finally possible in the sims 4 take a
look at some of the other folks from
around the studio
ah that's a great looking bunch but in
The Sims 4 3 2 sim is about more than
just how my sims look it's here where I
decide how my sims sound move and behave
I can choose how they walk through look
at that strut check out his swag I
choose their voices I give my sims
personality traits Mortimer is a genius
he's creative and a bit of a bookworm
I'm going to get Mortimer and aspiration
I want him to be a renaissance a room
making him a quick learner letting him
build skills faster Bella's a romantic
she's outgoing and active her aspiration
I want her to be a friend to the world
this unlocks the gregarious Drake she'll
be able to build friendships faster with
the power of create-a-sim I've designed
exactly the sims I want to play with
they all look great they're unique and
they have real personalities I'm going
to move my sim in with a bunch of
friends from the studio and build them a
house
ah home sweet home it looks like the
Goths are here to welcome the team and
Bella is already making some new friends
we can't wait to show you Bella and
Mortimer's home when we show off our new
build tools thanks for watching